[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 15 octobre
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition est la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
un nouveau patron pierre bédier a été
élu samedi lors du scrutin interne du
parti et le président du conseil
départemental a récolté près de 59% des
suffrages face à alexandra dublanche
vice-président de la région
explications et réactions à suivre dans
cette édition chaque année elles
touchent entre deux et six millions de
personnes en france la grippe peut être
mortelle chez les personnes fragiles la
campagne de vaccination a débuté depuis
le 6 octobre des yvelinois reçoivent des
bons pour aller chercher leurs vaccins
reportage dans une pharmacie de saint
rémy les chevreuse et puis elles sont
cinq étudiantes en formation d'assistant
de service social à mener ce projet
c'est yvelinoise vont partir pour une
mission humanitaire dans le sud du
vietnam en 2019
elle nous recevons sur ce plateau une
partie de l'équipe est aussi la
présidente de l'association enfance
partenariat et vietnam
on accueille tout de suite notre
première invitée dans ce journal
philippe brillault bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le maire va les républicains du
chesnay ou la taxe d'habitation a
augmenté de près de 10% vous allez nous
dire dans un instant pourquoi mais
d'abord vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
ce week-end se jouer un enjeu pour votre
parti dans les yvelines les élections
internes des républicains se sont tenues
et dans le département un samedi pierre
bédier a été élu dès le premier tour
président de la fédération une victoire
face à alexandra du blanche pour nous
parler de ses résultats et de l'avenir
de l'air 78 nicolas landry bonsoir
bonsoir grégory de la rédaction tv 78
alors quels sont les enseignements à
retenir de ce scrutin
nicollin est bien grégory l'expérience
politique a remporté l'a remporté face à
la jeunesse et au renouvellement l'homme
du grand chelem des sélections
départementales de 2014
pierre bédier a été élu président de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
avec 58 78 % des voix une victoire face
à alexandra du blanche elle a obtenu
41,22 % des suffrages
la conseillère régionale d'ile-de-france
qui de son côté voulait incarner le
renouveau écoutez sa réaction suite à ce
résultat
cette volonté de renouvellement et de
surtout de nouvelles façons de faire de
la politique je pense que il faut
qu'elle soit entendue
on est prêt à faire ce rassemblement
bien évidemment et j'espère qu'elle sera
entendue on en a beaucoup entendu parler
pendant la campagne maintenant faut
passer aux actes
et moi je crains une véritable
hémorragie des militants rhinois si
cette sensibilité n'était pas
étroitement associés à la vie future la
fédération après certaines tensions lors
de la campagne l'apaisement devrait être
au rendez vous et il a commencé dès hier
soir avec ce tweet d'autres magnats suu
kyi a félicité pierre bédier
objectif donc dans les prochaines
semaines le rassemblement de la droite
yvelinoise ont maintenant l'heure est au
rassemblement vraiment là besoin de se
rassembler tous ensemble autour de notre
nouveau prêt de ligands je pense que
bière aura à coeur de d'intégrer toutes
les bonnes volontés
avec une équipe représentative de tous
les territoires de toutes les
sensibilités de tous les gages d'une
survie d'une forte capacité de
mobilisation de rassemblement il a
montré plusieurs fois l'air il est élu
député il a il a une certaine expérience
aussi du parlement il est ministre il a
eu beaucoup quand même de 2 2 il a été
maire et maire d'une
d'une commune très difficile de la
circonscription quand même très
difficile
bien sûr qu'il faut des gens
d'expérience et après maintenant il faut
rassembler parce que dans toutes les
élections démocratiques dont vous avez
un moment un peu difficile entre les
deux équipes avec une participation
proche des 60 4% sur 4600 adhérents les
militants les républicains des yvelines
se sentaient donc concernés par cette
élection
après ce scrutin la reconstruction de la
fédération peut commencer avec une
vision très précise du nouveau président
de la fédération dans les prochains
jours je vais réunir celles et ceux qui
vont constituer avec moi le bureau il va
y avoir un triptyque qui est un
triptyque animations information
formation et on va mettre en place
immédiatement ce triptyque donc il faut
désigner celui qui va être celle ou
celui qui va être responsable de la
formation c'est celui qui va être
responsable de l'information
même chose pour l'animation pierre
bédier a assuré que des actions seraient
mises en oeuvre avant la fin de l'année
le 23 octobre prochain un calendrier
sera arrêtée avec les différents élus
des circonscriptions alors si brio vous
vous êtes membre des républicains des
yvelines votre réaction suite à cette
élection de pierre bédier va d'abord il
fallait être courageux pour faisant tu
es une candidature face à pierre bédier
donc moi je félicite alexandre à 2,7
présenté il ya une conseillère
départementale qui d'addicts on suivant
le jeune pour vite l'ancien connaître
trajet aujourd'hui on a un président
pierre bédier on doit tous être derrière
il ya un vrai challenge maintenant il
faut reconstruire et bien allons-y puis
on va voir merci nicolas pour ses
réactions et fibres et on vous retrouve
dans un instant pour parler du chéné
juste avant une autre élection c'était
la municipale c'est la municipale
coignières à coignières donc le 25
novembre et 2 décembre elle est devenue
nécessaire après la démission du maire
jean-pierre se vanterait de plusieurs
élus un candidat s'est déclaré
officiellement david pelletier actuel
adjoint aux finances qui avait un ton
assuré l'intérim à la tête de la commune
sa liste sans étiquette agir ensemble
pour coignières se fixe trois priorités
modernité solidarité gouvernance
citoyenne et
environnement deux autres listes
devaient devrait être également en lice
dont celle de l'opposant socialiste
didier fischer
c'était une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron supprimer la taxe
d'habitation une suppression qui se fait
en trois temps et qui devrait concerner
80 % des français pourtant beaucoup de
contribuables ont constaté sur leur avis
d'imposition une hausse de cette taxe
d'habitation
environ 6000 des 36000 communes de
france ont choisi d'augmenter leur taux
alors c'est le terrain dans votre
commune philippe brillault je rappelle
que vous êtes le maire les républicains
du chesnay ou la taxe d'habitation a
progressé de quasi 10% pourquoi ce choix
d'abord c'est pas un choix c'est une
contrainte en fait si 10 % correspondent
à l'équivalent de 1 million 3 de
recettes
sachant que le déficit en montant dans
le bus j'ai été 2009 comprenant
considérer que la ville allait faire des
économies pour un million en 6 et le
million 3 bat saurais je dirais
apportées par les habitants ça
représente à peu près 60 euros par foyer
et par an sachant que quelque part la
moyenne de la taxe d'habitation déchaîné
jien est de 670 euros était de 6 ans on
dit elle sera un petit peu plus de 700
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu on a
eu une contravention une pénalité d'un
million 3 brutalement 2018
parce que nous n'avions pas nos 25 % de
logements sociaux comme un grand nombre
de communes
voilà donc c'est une amende ponctuelles
et notre travail avec la ville dort au
concours au niveau de la fusion va nous
permettre normalement de ne pas avoir
cette contravention 2019 et donc
probablement certainement de rendre
l'argent qu'on tribal ce n'est pas le
cas de toutes les communes
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est choquant
que nous soyons tagué par le
gouvernement pour dire voilà sur le
permanent à d'ailleurs salué les maires
qui la responsabilité des maires qu'ils
n'augmenteraient pas cette taxe ça veut
dire ça veut dire quoi comment vous le
prenez que la commune du chêne et
irresponsable voulait produire comme ça
non j'ai pas envie de commander ça
j'aurais aimé qu'on dise que pendant
cinq ans n'a pas du tout augmenter les
impôts
les impôts c'est une variable
d'ajustement dans le système financier
des collectivités
aujourd'hui la taxe d'habitation
représentent chez nous 25% des recettes
de la ville
il est clair que l'état est en train
en fait de demander aux communes de
s'auto financer eux mêmes de se
désengager et donc quelque part qu'elles
vont être nos recettes ou la fiscalité
la taxe d'habitation l'existant pu même
s'il est compensé par l'état prend même
temps elle le sera ce sera la taxe
foncière ou les prestations nous de
pouvoir d'achat on a décidé de le
maintenir dans la baisse de nos
prestations c'est que toute prestation
la piscine la cantine scolaire les
crèches ou autre c'est quelque part la
fiscalité qui la financent aujourd'hui
les chaînes essien c'est par foyer deux
euros par jour pour l'ensemble de ce
qu'on leur donne parler de la fusion
avec rocancourt qui sera effective au
1er janvier 2019 ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui cette hausse au chesnay
annonce une peut-être une stabilisation
une réduction l'année prochaine parce
que le chesnay meurt le 31 décembre de
cette année une nouvelle commune de
chesney rocancourt comme c'est une
nouvelle commune on n'a pas de
référentiel pendant trois ans et on a
une dgf dotation globale de
fonctionnement figé pour je dirais trois
ans avec une dotation de 5 % donc
effectivement nous sommes rentrés dans
l'ère de la mutualisation alors je
voulais juste dire quelque chose
d'important vous et je vous amener ici
le rôle
les services des impôts donne à chaque
ville ce qu'on appelle le rôle sur
quinze mille foyers que nous avons au
chesnay 12 1249 payer une taxe
d'habitation alors pourquoi les autres
ne paye pas parce que lorsque les
non-imposables on ne paye pas de taxes
d'habitation et combien font l'objet
d'une compensation de l'état 708 sur
12480 708 c'est pour des questions de
handicap hôtes sont compensées par la
commune nous ne savons absolument pas à
la date d'aujourd'hui
combien de foyers vont bénéficier de
l'avantagé
macron et donc c'est ça ce que nous
reprochons quand on a fait notre budget
on ne savait rien et aujourd'hui on dit
c'est une rotation pour les communes
est-ce que vous en voyez la couleur
aujourd'hui de celle on pense à sion on
verra la compensation dans le rôle
l'année prochaine donc ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas été associé ce qui est
quand même bien dommage quand on va
préparer le budget on aurait su qu'est
ce qu'on aurait fait donc les gens qui
ont une baisse de leur taxe d'habitation
de toutes les façons m'ont payé moins
cher que ce qu'ils devaient payer et les
10%
c'est vraiment pour notons qu elle mais
je pense à toutes les communes qui
essaye de gérer au mieux leurs
prestations alors flinguer le maire
c'est facile c'est un peu une méthode
qu'il faudrait éviter d'ailleurs je
pense que le gouvernement est en train
de regarder que c'est pas forcément la
méthode on apprenne
public qui veut on a un gouvernement qui
essaye de faire et des députés qui
feront peut-être bien attention à faire
ce qu'ils ont à faire aujourd'hui un
maire et l'équipe municipale elle a pas
une étiquette politique
elle a la responsabilité de satisfaire
toutes les compétences politiques de sa
commune
c'est ce qu'une décision de faire et
nous sommes 36000 communes à travailler
à fond pour ce faire merci et philippe
brillault d'avoir été avec nous je vous
en prie rappelle que vous êtes le maire
les républicains à du chesnay un groupe
de citoyen yvelinois l'assemblée
nationale parents et enfants venus de
versailles en cours et montigny le
bretonneux se sont rendus samedi dans
l'hémicycle accueilli par le député la
république en marche de la première
circonscription des yvelines est didier
baichère pour une visite récompense pour
avoir remporté récemment le radis de
l'europe organisées sur le territoire de
la circonscription un jeu pour mieux
comprendre l'union européenne santé 2 à
6 millions de personnes sont touchées
par la grippe chaque hiver une maladie
qui peut se révéler grave voire mortelle
chez les personnes fragiles elles la
campagne de vaccination a débuté depuis
le 6 octobre
regardez ce reportage de marie lehn
iapichino et mélanie poker je vous
donnais une petite pochette pour le
transport et multi d'accord vous ne
verrez pas de sortir de l'approché comme
chaque année michel houdebine les 84 ans
vient chercher son vaccin contre la
grippe parce que quand on entre un peu
la grille moi je lui une fois j'avais je
tiens or jeune j'étais bien bon point
est trop jeune en 2010 est de 159 milles
yvelinois avait bénéficié d'un bon de
prise en compte plus de 42 % d'entre eux
se sont fait vacciner
nous avons ici la moitié du stock en
invité parce que nous faisons livré en
deux fois pour des problèmes de places
dont tous les enfants eux mêmes systèmes
on s'approvisionne au plus tôt des
stocks pensé dès le mois de février
les premiers vaccins sont arrivés à la
fin du mois de septembre
cette pharmacie de saint rémy les
chevreuse a déjà délivré 136 vaccins au
moins d'une semaine et on a eu beaucoup
de demandes
même avant le début de la campagne de
vaccination qui a démarré le 5 ou le 6
octobre selon les caisses
c'est important parce que ça protège soi
même et ça protège l'entourage aussi il
faut savoir que des personnes sensibles
peuvent être contaminés par des
personnes non vaccinées
je parle des petits enfants et des
personnes âgées
cette année encore dans les yvelines
c'est le médecin ou l'infirmier qui fait
l'injection mais les pharmaciens
pourraient bientôt vacciner eux-mêmes
une expérimentation est en cours dans
quatre autres départements français
les travaux avaient débuté en juillet
2010 est l'école maternelle gustave
flaubert rénové a été inauguré ce samedi
à trappes
huit cent soixante sept mille euros ont
été déboursés pour mes moderniser
l'établissement nouvelle salle
polyvalente création d'un espace pour
les atsem ou encore réfection complète
de l'électricité seul chauffage et
sanitaire une cour de récréation
repenser également avec des jeux
pédagogiques pour favoriser la mixité
fille garçon sur les dix dernières
années est 19 écoles ont été rénovés à
trappes
l'équipe en a été également inauguré
samedi une piste cyclable entre la ville
de bois d'arcy et l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines une zone
sécurisée longue de 700 m en dénivelé
qui part de la zone de la croix bonnet
coût total 390 mille euros financés par
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
et des étudiantes évinoise en mission
humanitaire au vietnam elles sont cinq à
partir en 2019 dans le sud du pays elle
nous recevons sur ce plateau 3 d'antenne
trois d'entre elles par dont marion le
laurent clémence lauret et inès pro
caisse on sort en salles entre ok ce
n'est pas très bien vous êtes venu avec
florence cavaliers bonsoir êtes la
présidente de l'association enfance
partenariat vietnam qui accompagne ce
projet d'abord présenté nous cette
association quelles sont ses missions
alors cette association à 11 ans et nous
avons des missions en santé éducation et
amélioration des conditions de vie au
vietnam
nous sommes tous bénévoles nous n'avons
donc 4 % de frais de fonctionnement et
nous avons grosso modo 500 adhérents et
depuis onze ans nous envoyant des jeunes
en séjour solidaire à leurs frais au
vietnam sur une mission soit en santé
éducation ou amélioration des conditions
de vie donc ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il a ce genre d'opération avec
des étudiants avec des jeunes
en fait nous envoyons des jeunes au
vietnam alors si on doit présenter ce
voyage quand se déroulera-t-il pardon on
va y arriver elle combien de temps va
durer la mission quelle zone du pays ça
va concerner du coup on part donc on est
cinq à partir on her également avec
adèle et mélodies on part dans le sud du
vietnam avons tao dong est à peu près
deux heures et demie de hô chi minh et
nous partons pendant un mois donc tout
le mois de l'année prochaine 2019
on commencera à peu près c'est une aide
de détails ou par une date de départ qui
est prévu aux alentours du 27 avril et
on reviendrait le 1er juin
alors petit tour de table pourquoi cette
mission humanitaire qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à vous engager dans une mission
humanitaire
clémence alors ce qui nous a poussés à
nous lancer dans cette mission
humanitaire c'est déjà parce que on a
tout un intérêt pour l'enfance donc pour
le coup partir dans un orphelinat au
vietnam
c'est quelque chose de nouveau pour nous
même de découvrir ce qu'est un
orphelinat dans un autre pays que la
france
c'est quelque chose qui nous tient à
coeur et puis ça regroupe des valeurs
qu'on rassemble tout et qu'on aimerait
et qu'on aimerait appliquer la barre
voilà on précise juste que vous êtes en
formation d'assistant de service social
c'est à dire que c'est en lien direct
avec votre formation mal en fait fait on
est en congé en tout en 2e année
d'assistant de service social
durant nos études donc cette deuxième
année on a six mois de stage à effectuer
et on a la chance de pouvoir partir dans
le cadre de nos derniers mois de stage
au vietnam
une convention qui a été passé entre
notre école et du coup l'association de
même cavalier le pvn ce qui nous permet
de pouvoir partir pendant notre cadre de
notre stage au vietnam que vous
souhaitiez dire un mot à marion
peut-être sur pour le pourquoi vous
engagez dans une mission humanitaire
de l'autre côté j'ai fait des études
avant j'ai fait un baccalauréat
professionnel est ce service à la
personne et du coup j'ai pu travailler
en crèche
donc c'est un lien avec ma formation
d'avant que je pourrais mettre au profit
des enfants au vietnam alors florent
cette question s'adresse à vous pourquoi
le vietnam pourquoi finalement mener des
actions au vietnam quelles sont les
urgences sur place alors les urgences en
fait toutes ces jeunes filles donc son
en études d'assistante sociale et du
coup dans les orphelinats on a des
problématiques d'accès à l'emploi pour
des jeunes défavorisés de jeunes qui
peuvent être entraînés dans la rue avec
des situations compliquées de drogue de
prostitution
donc ces jeunes vont travailler avec les
autorités locales
nous nous mêmes nous travaillons
régulièrement avec l'ambassade du
vietnam et l'ambassade de france et donc
conjointement ces jeunes vont
faire profiter en fait le vietnam de
toute leur expérience de tout leur
savoir pour qu'ils aient une
co-construction avec les autorités sur
place et de façon à prendre en charge le
mieux possible ces jeunes mais comment
ça se passe sur place elles sont avec
des membres de votre association alors
sur place nous avons une psychologue qui
travaille dans cet orphelinat et qui est
anglophone et qui va effectivement les
suivre pendant tout leur tout leur
séjour et bien en amont elles ont déjà
travaillé un petit peu chacune leur
domaine d'activité on a travaillé déjà
avec les autorités on va faire traduire
tous leurs cours en anglais et donc du
coup elles vont faire vraiment de la
formation professionnelle en maintenant
temps qu'un travail social avec les
jeunes orphelins de cette structure
alors il nous reste deux minutes on va
aller un petit peu plus vite les
missions sur place concrètement durant
votre séjour va mettre en place des
ateliers préventif et éducatif
donc qu'ils aborderont la prostitution
la sexualité le corps humain ensuite la
scolarité et l'insertion professionnelle
professionnels pardon la sécurité
routière la citoyenneté et le bien-être
et puis pour finir les pratiques
addictives donc l'alcool le tabac et les
drogues mais florence le disais c'est un
sans voyage bien sûr qu'ils se préparent
en amont comment ça se prépare un tel
voyage
nous préparons en différentes étapes
donc d'abord on rencontre très souvent
madame cavaliers pour préparer donc le
projet élaboré nos missions et on se
regroupe très souvent tout les 5 pour
pouvoir du coup répondre aux différents
mails qu'on reçoit faire des demandes de
bourses de mécénat on fait aussi des
demandes
on a fait aussi des démarches pour avoir
des dons matériels donc des produits
d'hygiène et des fournitures scolaires
dans différents établissements et on est
en train justement de mettre en place
une cagnotte pour récolter des fonds
financiers pour nous aider à organiser
des sorties différentes sorties là bas
les activités emmené du matériel
spécifique et donc vous pouvez nous
aider
c'est bien simple ils se sont peut-être
affiché pendant l'entretien où on peut
venir on peut contacter vous aider vous
avez besoin de combien grosso modo pour
pour financer ses missions sur place on
aurait pas de but
et on ne sait pas vraiment fixé un
budget si c'est vrai que tous ce qui est
enfin oui tout ce qu'on aura la fierté
de toute façon sera le bienvenu comme
disait marion on a besoin d'eux aussi de
dons matériau est là pour l'instant on a
déjà récolté pas mal tout ce qui est peu
lui chaut via un jeu pour enfants et
c'est vrai que tant qu'on ne peut avoir
des choses qui de façon ça profitera aux
enfants sur place donc voilà c'est le
mieux pour nous et les coordonnées de
votre votre opération sont sont affichés
en bas de l'écran merci à vous marion
clémence et inès et merci également à
florence cavaliers de l'association en
france partenariat vietnam on vous
souhaite pleine réussite dans ce projet
que vous pouvez soutenir vos
téléspectateurs pour ce faire rendez
vous comme je voulais dire sur les liens
à qui s'affiche en bas de cet écran
après une pause technique le bibliobus
revient sur les communes de saint
quentin en yvelines il s'agit d'une
médiathèque itinérante l'inauguration de
ce service s'est déroulée samedi à
elancourt sur place marylène iapichino
leray et le récit de manon par aldo ça
roule à nouveau pour le bibliobus ce
véhicule itinérant permet d'accéder à
une sélection de documents sans se
rendre en médiathèque et d'importants de
compléter et de relayer l'offre des
médiathèques
en allant plus près des habitants 1 aux
endroits où les médiathèques sont un peu
éloignés des textes qu on appelle les
zones blanches et puis vers les publics
qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer les
personnes peuvent également récupérer ou
rendre les documents commander sur le
portail i médiathèque ou emprunter à
lille il faut être à ce que la
médiathèque ou au bibliobus ans pour ce
faire il faut remplir un contrat
d'adhésion ça le contrat d'adhésion
permet d'emprunter
tous supports vivre pour quatre à six
semaines et
vous pouvez devenir au bus comme vous
pouvez venir dans n'importe quel média
taille du réseau vous pouvez également
réserver sur le portail des médiathèques
en indiquant
la tournée du bus et y'a pas de soucis
on est là ce véhicule neuf
habillé des dessins de l'auteur et
illustrateur philippe ugg continuera ses
arrêts pour le plus grand plaisir des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
collyre délivré et au civil c'est bien
d'apporter la lecture on peut avancer ça
on est dans les écoles et ça venait
devant les écoles et les enfants aller
faire un petit tour et emprunter donc
plus on peut apporter à la littérature
et l'élu plaisir de lire aux enfants
mieux c'est le bibliobus à d'autres
arrêts programmés il sera par exemple le
samedi à magny les hameaux dès 10h30 au
centre social le buisson des
informations complémentaires sont à
retrouver sur le site de la médiathèque
de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
vous en avez désormais l'habitude tous
les lundis les sur ce plateau miquel et
demi d'euros bonsoir monsieur sport de
cette rédaction alors vous décrypter
pour nous elle les résultats du week end
dans le département beaucoup d'émotion
notamment écran baseball les cougars
montigny-le-bretonneux commence par du
baseball les cougars de monti le
bretonneux n'ont pas réussi à décrocher
le premier titre de champion de france
de leur histoire
des signes montrent un ont perdu ce
samedi le troisième match de leur série
contre rouen sur le score de 2 à 0
les cougars pourront se consoler en se
disant qu'ils ont tout simplement
réalisé le plus beau parcours de
l'histoire du club
ils sont également qualifiés pour la
coupe d'europe une première pour
montigny le bretonneux
on a déjà hâte de les retrouver la
saison prochaine les oreilles on les
retrouvera tout de suite après ce
journal dans leurs études pour votre
émission puisqu'ils viendront le deux
ensemble sur le plateau toute l'équipe
sera présente y aura du monde sur ce
plateau de tv 78 on continue miquel part
du rugby là encore des émotions
direction le championnat de division
honneur versailles n'en finit à plus de
gagner ce dimanche les versailles en
entendant j'ai leur quatrième victoire
de la saison en autant de matches en
s'imposant à domicile 26 à 9 contre le
rc paris 15 avec quatre essais inscrits
on écoute les réactions on a eu un petit
passage en 6 points un temps faible en
fin de première période on a remis les
bouchées doubles en début le début de
deuxième mi temps et sait gérer pas que
ce sens force l on a few confiance
confiance en nos forces on est au dessus
dans le sens pour la confiance on a
confiance en nos forces et quand on
arrive à jouer simplement on peut
arriver à mettre en difficulté n'importe
qui on est très contents très satisfait
l'engagement dégâts et de ce qu'ils
produisent à l'entraînement donc on est
sur la bonne la bonne voie une belle
ambiance en tout cas sur ces images les
gorilles avec cette victoire les joueurs
de la cité royale s'envole déjà au
classement l'équipe compte quatre points
d'avancé sur clichy après seulement
quatre journées dans ce championnat de
la division leur part du football et et
de la coupe de france va-t-on pouvoir
continuer à arriver avec les club
yvelinois
on peut dire oui grégory mais c'est
quand même un peu contrastée cinquième
tour ou donc contrasté pour les
yvelinois les principaux résultats du
département ça passe pour verser qui
s'impose 3 1 sur le terrain de saint
germain sentry poissy sera également
présent au 6e tour les pisciacais ont
dominé lille
ea guingamp 3-2 après prolongations
c'est terminé pour ou et qui s'incline
aux tirs au but contre ivry
même scénario pour les mureaux sur le
terrain de saint maur epône se fait
sortir par bobigny 3 à 0 et conflans
perd contre fleury mérogis 2 à 1
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon et
puis notre page hebdomadaire dédiée à la
découverte de la vallée de chevreuse ce
soir nous allons voir la gestion de
l'évolution de la nature à bonnel
comment gérer ces espaces préservés à la
diversité de ses espèces qui y vivent ce
sont notamment des chantiers nature
participative qui le permettent un
reportage de jules colis à prendre sur
le terrain voilà l'objectif de ces
élèves sur ce chantier nature à beaune l
au delà d'un simple exercice s'est mise
en pratique permettent aux étudiants de
travailler sur des situations concrètes
comme ici en entretenant un sentier de
randonnée
l'objectif de cet aménagement est de
permettre de rendre ce sentiers
praticables par les randonneurs en leur
aménageant des passerelles qui leur
permettent de passer au dessus de 6 donc
le but c'était de d'installer des
passerelles donc on a creusé place et
des rondins de bois
ensuite on a utilisé des sortes de
plaquettes qui était donc déjà nos
dispositions en bois on les a portés
dont canon qu'avec tes des grandes
équipes on les a donc disposé on a
essayé de les renforcer pour que du coup
ça soit bien enfoncés dans le sol et que
ça tienne bien fruit d'une collaboration
entre le parc régional de la vallée de
chevreuse et l'école tecomah à jouy en
josas
ces événements sont bénéfiques à tous
donc le partenariat est intéressant
entre notre école et le parc naturel
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse puisque nous avons la chance
grâce aux containers de découvrir des
endroits et des sites naturels protégés
est classé et d'intervenir en respectant
une commande tu as bien réel et qui
permet aux élèves d'être vraiment mises
en situation concrètes les élèves ça
leur permet d'apprendre un peu de
découvrir les milieux de découvrir les
techniques de de découvrir les manières
de gérer ces milieux et noom ça nous
permet d'avoir à chaque fois entre 20 et
25 jeunes très motivés avec des
professeurs qui les encadre très bien
passé quelque chose de très enrichissant
car ça nous permet donc justement où
confronté à la réalité du terrain de
tester la théorie à la pratique donc sur
le lieu même mes devoirs
justement si déjà ce genre de métier
pour une eau claire plus tard un
partenariat s'effectue en une fois par
mois depuis trois ans qui s'avère
enrichissant pour les élèves comme pour
les communes
c'est la fin du set 8 journal replay sur
notre application mobile et sur notre
site internet belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]